the terrifying Hellraiser saga
surrounding pinhead and his nefarious
band of Cinna bites continues in
Hellraiser judgment with more puzzle
boxes hapless victims and of course a
few trips to 55 Lodovico place this time
there's a serial Slayer on the loose in
the earthly realm doling out justice for
various violations of the Ten
Commandments as some sort of sick scheme
to win God's favor meanwhile panhead and
his pals have been exacting their own
brand of justice and hell and when the
two worlds collide well there's you know
what to pay be rules shoes let's take a
look at how the story draws everything
together and sets up the next round of
Hell raising harsh judgment pinheads new
right hand man or thing is the most
interesting addition to the film called
the auditor this slashed face batty
begins the process of eternal judgment
on pinheads behalf I'm a mindful
campaign is nothing more than the common
currency naturally this is all very
gross for everyone involved
after the auditor types up a human's
confession another sidekick called the
Assessor Chows down on the pages and
regurgitates them up for a trio of
jurors who rifle through the contents
and then render their verdict
punishment then begins with a disgusting
saliva bath before the subject is sent
to the butcher and the surgeon for some
key rearrangements
so yeah it's foul in every imaginable
way and whoever ends up at the cotton
house is in for quite an unpleasant
surprise unless detective with a dark
side at first we're led to believe that
Detective Shawn Carter is just a man
who's far too into his job of hunting
down serial killers he comes home late
to his angry wife can't seem to stay
away from work and is even being
investigated by the cases newest pair of
eyes detective Christine Edgerton is
here to help but she also believes he
might be suffering from PTSD from his
war service maybe dabbling in drugs or
alcohol his brother David who is somehow
his partner in crime fighting thinks
he's a rational and good person and
gladly follows him down whatever rabbit
hole as investigations take him through
by the end of the film however we find
out that looks have been very deceiving
when it comes to Sean it just
terrible ponderous chain you all make
he's actually the one who's taken on the
mantle of righteous death-dealer
slaughtering people who run afoul of the
ten commandments in pretty much any way
shape or form between him underlining
the same Charles Dickens quotes from the
crime scenes to his obsession with
Ecclesiastes which roughly translates to
the very name of the man thereafter he
implicates himself pretty well along the
way judge the righteous and his crimes
are unspeakable he saws off the hands
eyeballs and teeth of some teens while
they're still alive simply because they
committed petty theft he surgically
implants a woman's womb with her still
living dog because she says in a phone
video that she worships the animal it's
so bad that even the Assessor can't
stomach the taste of his confessions and
yet he manages to escape judgment twice
because of a demand from on high the
powers that be it seems like pinhead
holds the ultimate authority over how
guilty people are treated in his domain
but when the Archangel Joe feels shows
up and insists that David be sent back
to earth to finish his work which at
first we think is just solid policing
then heads team has no choice but to
concede
chances pin head still sends his
stitched twins along to hunt as
nightmares but he mostly steers clear of
Shawn after Shawn brings himself back to
pinheads realm again though in the hopes
of trading his brother and wife for his
own soul being cleared pan head and his
auditor refused to bargain with him or
Joe feel they're ready to move on to the
punishment phase and chaining Shawn's
brother and wife up to a state of
eternal suffering won't satisfy their
bloodlust Joe feel wants him to be sent
back to earth to carry on with his
Commandments laughter's so more people
will turn to the Almighty for protection
this makes Shawn believe his plan is
falling into place but Joe feel informs
him that he's not getting any absolution
out of this arrangement he'll still be
pinheads property after it's all said
and done but she just wants to buy him
more time for his bad deed the trouble
is hen has grown weary of blindly
obeying Joe feels demands the final
judgement at first Penn head obliges Joe
feels request to return Shawn to the
living so he can score the good sides of
souls but when Shawn regains
consciousness he's immediately waxed by
detective Edgerton who has now figured
out he's the big bad they've been
looking for
Shawn's instant demise puts him back in
pinheads clutches for good this time and
that angers Joe feel who threatens to
bring down the wrath of her boss for his
insolence pened decides he's got nothing
to lose though he's already in hell and
was basically built to endure such
suffering so how much worse could it get
for him not only does he ignore her
warnings pened also proceeds to throw
the angel into his chains lets them rip
her to shreds
even the auditor knows his boss has made
a massive mistake as he points out Joe
feel was the angel who banished Adam and
Eve from the Garden of Eden and if she
could do it to them she could do
something similar to pinhead just as all
those he's judged have awoken to the
harsh consequences of their mistakes
the last scene finds a humanized version
of pinhead banished from his realm of
sweet suffering and sent to the mortal
realm meanwhile the post-credits scene
opens the door for the auditor to take
over all together as he's shown in
Hannover Germany welcoming to
unsuspecting missionaries into his
lethal lair
- and it isn't even a true step thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]